merci monsieur le président l'europe est
traversée par une crise sans précédent
qui risque de mettre à mal son avenir et
remettre en cause sa construction alors
même qu'elle est vitale
cela nous sommes nombreux à ne pas
l'accepter et c'est pourquoi je voudrais
tant que l'ensemble des institutions
européennes la commission le conseil
notre parlement soit à la hauteur du
moment que nous vivons et il y a une
chose qu'il faut éviter à tout prix
c'est continuer de faire comme si rien
ne s'était passé
business as usual c'est un risque majeur
qui nous guette tous le programme dont
nous parlons aujourd'hui il devrait être
le contraire d'un catalogue
il devrait tenir en un seul mot
reconstruire refonder réforme et
repenser notre union européenne notre
communauté européenne lui redonner à
l'horizon dans lequel les peuples se
retrouveront c'est la seule façon d'être
au rendez vous de l'histoire